express each of the following ratios in
the simplest ball which I read just like
take a fraction and write it in its
simplest form
okay so 1a is 12 to 18 okay hopefully
I'm going to say this so many times get
a good secret but in your head if I've
written this is a fraction 12 over 18
what would you do to both numbers to
make it simpler
I should divide by the highest common
factor which in this case is 6 ok so if
I divide each one by 6 divided by 6
divided by 6 right
that'll give me and I read it out as 2 2
3 ok that's whatever it yep exactly
right exactly it's a it's a language
thing it's much like well why do we have
percentages and fractions when we
establish the other day you know honey
1/2 and 50% and 0.5 they all true the
argument the same think you shouldn't
waste good question why would we as we
move through this other way further
you'll see times where it's much more
natural to speak in this language then
in this language so give it about 10
minutes machine ok all right let's have
a look at - sure ok again we did yeah
okay now have a look at two a it says
one point two two zero point two okay
now in this case this is a bit weird you
know neither of the numbers are just
hold on okay so what I would do first is
I'll just multiply both by ten I want I
just want whole numbers and then I can
work with it right so if I multiply this
one by ten and multiply this one by ten
okay what will I get
I'll get twelve to two okay and now I do
just want to do before
what's the number I divide through it'll
be - why not - by two divide this by 2
and you get 6 to 1 okay
divide each one okay good
all right last one let's just do three
Hey okay so it just gives you a fraction
there one and a half to two okay we're
gonna hafta - sir in just the same way
as I did in question two right because
the numbers aren't whole I'll multiply
by something make it bigger and then
I'll see if I need to simplify any
further so what would I multiply by to
change things in two whole numbers hmm I
want this forever I can't if I'm not by
the one I'll still get the same numbers
I'm gonna multiply by two now the reason
why you go to is because there's a half
there right for x - you don't get rid of
it so if I multiply this by 2 and this
by 2 one and a half times two that's
three and of course two times two is
four now at that point we do we did
before and check do I need to simplify
anything I'm here to another three or
four it's as simple as it gets
okay yes
yeah okay so all I'm thinking of let me
let me pull it back to those other
questions we did with fractions right if
I had 12 over 18 okay
and I want to simplify or reduce it to
its simplest point I think of that it's
called the number it's called the
highest common factor that's a number
which would divide into 12 and divide
into 18 and leave me with whole numbers
okay and so you check through your like
what's the biggest number that I can
divide this by and this by and still get
a whole number out the answer is 6
okay now in these cases I had to do
rather than dividing I had to multiply
do you remember why I multiply it's
because these numbers I hold right I
want whole numbers at the end so that's
why I multiplied and then I simplified a
little for them okay yeah yeah which
part here yeah okay now in some ways I
didn't have to choose 10 but I just try
to get rid of these decimals I know what
decimals I want to know with whole
numbers at the end so I chose 10 because
it's easy because all I have to do is
move the decimal place one point to 12
it's around 0.2 yeah that's right
if I had more decimals suppose I had
something like under one point 3 5 and I
don't know 0.1 see how I've got 2
decimal places there so to get rid of
all the decimal places I'll multiply
that by a hundred and I've got to
multiply that by a hundred as well okay
so I just choose whatever round number
will make it so that's how is 10 that's
why I choose 100 here I chose 2 because
I saw this excellent you don't know